okay i'm gonna play ed fast this is
rated blitz
i'll turn off the sound we'll try and be
serious i'll admit i don't know so much
stat or so much um
not stafford traxler
i feel like traxler is a similar
category to stafford
probably slightly more sound
okay so i've been bribed to play this
opening
and oh no i got forked
this is apparently opening theory though
[Music]
i know i'm supposed to take and then
take on
e4
but at foss definitely knows a lot more
than me
so i guess my goal is to
try and deviate from theory i'm pretty
sure this is a move
like bishop here
um let's try and focus
okay taking this seriously now
this is all i remember bishop g4
bishop e2 there's some knight d4 at some
point
maybe i could play 94 right away
actually
threatening to trap the queen if it
takes i assume this looks fine
and frost's still clearly prepared
that move is unsettling
maybe i can take
stick with queen too
[Music]
i'll take this way idea d5 eventually
wow yeah this is still some obscure
theory
okay i have this move too
it's hard to play this opening without
knowing anything
okay so if here queen e1 knight c2 let's
do this
it looks fun though
[Music]
okay i feel better now now that uh
opponent's taking some time this
actually looks really fun
but also kind of scary because i'm down
a rook and a bishop
and i'm out of tea oh no my tea
yeah that's a move so i want to play
i have d5 too maybe d5
it's bishop d3
ah so there's this this this wait a
minute
there's a very pesky move queen f7 in
these lines
so i think i should play d5 first
at very least i should win the night and
then i'll only be on the rook and then
the
king should be still very sus
down about a minute i mean that's
expected though
okay so maybe i should have played this
but not sure
trying to keep my options open and this
also some idea
because the bishops attacked once
defended once
i'm actually really curious to check out
the theory after this game
because at some point i i'm sure i
strayed away from
main line theory
but i guess that's the thing about
traxxar it's still like these positions
are so complex
so this move there's king g now let's
play this move
no i saw that right after i moved there
too
oh no my queen
oh no
it's checkmate it's checkmates
oh let's go oh that's so beautiful look
at this move
look at this move so my queen was pinned
but after night here
so i'll i'll be completely honest when
bishop a3 was played i was
actually um in some trauma
and then i only saw this like a second
before i played
it but the it's incredible like
to check the king
white blocked the check white escaped
the check and checked my king
and it looks like i'm in trouble but
after this move i block the
i block the check i check
but also double check and it's just meet
oh that was so that's so beautiful
so many works of art today
thanks for whoever bribed me to play one
more game
um wait a minute is this
is this force mate
wait engine is giving plus why is white
better here
am i hallucinating oh king e1 is check
wait a minute it's still complicated
though
so obviously i can't get away with this
because takes and
still lose the queen but it's still
tricky because after this
if i lose my queen here it's this is
meat right
that's mate it's very easy to
hallucinate in this position
and if here
oh this is check as well
and i'm not quite mating because the
king's going to have a square
but even in this line i think after king
ji there's queen f7
giving the king a square and then white
can take and be okay
um that was a funny line though
so we both we both made a couple of
blunders this game
of course yeah king g1 kg1 looks like
such a safe move too
[Music]
that's a funny oh it's a funny graph as
well
so engine says i was losing most of the
game
oh if king e3 knight f5 yeah key e3
knight f5
double check it's not quite mate and i
think white is winning here right oh
it's made in two
oh wow knight f2
always calculate further here and then
this is made
oh that's so funny
so in this position the only move to
survive is king e1
other moves get mated by force
that's so cool i should play the tracks
for more often after a game like this
um
i should also make an effort to like
learn some theory too
[Music]
so as far as i know that the engine
doesn't
fully grasp these lines like it just
says equal but it's
the position's so crazy
it's also weird because engine will say
like it's equal and then we play the
two best moves d5 takes and then sets
plus four
so apparently i should play knight d4
immediately which oh which i did
but we we followed some theory here
wow so d6 apparently is a refutation
[Music]
it's according to masters database
i took play bishop g4 so i'm following
like the most common line
i guess ad floss just knew the
essentially the refutation
and things can branch out from here
now this position is still wild though